- [Voiceover] We've
got three bananas here.
One, two, three.
So I'm starting with three bananas
and I want to add some number of bananas
so that I end up with 10 bananas.
So this is what I'm starting with.
I'm starting with three
and I want to end up with 10.
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven,
eight, nine, ten.
So what do I have to add to the three
to get to 10?
I encourage you to pause this video
and try this out on your own.
So let's work through this.
So let's just start adding bananas.
So that's three.
So now let me add a fourth.
That would be my fourth banana.
Five bananas.
Six bananas.
Seven bananas.
Eight bananas.
Nine bananas.
And ten bananas.
So how many bananas did I add?
So now I added some
number of bananas here.
So in total I have one,
two, three, four, five,
six, seven, eight, nine, ten.
So how many did I have to add to the three
in order to get to the total of 10
in order to get this 10 right over here?
We could just count these.
This is one, this is two, this is three,
four, five, six, seven.
I added seven bananas.
I added seven bananas to
the original three bananas
to get to 10.
So three plus seven is equal to 10.
And you can see that what
we have on this left side
is indeed equal to what
we have on the right side.
On the left side we have
one, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight, nine, ten bananas
and on the right hand side
we have one, two, three,
four, five, six, seven, eight, nine, ten.
So they are indeed equal.